- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is live your life.
Over to you, Ben Affleck.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- If you could give advice
to your 25-year-old self,
what would you say?
- You know, I'd be inclined to say,
watch out for this guy and
don't spend money on this
and buy real estate right up until 2007
and then dump it all, that kind of thing.
- Oh, that's good advice.
- But the truth is about
youth and experience
and success and failure
is that you just have to go
live it and experience it.
And if you don't, it doesn't
make you a mature adult.
I think that you're
defined by how you rise
more than how you fall.
- One of the most important
lessons that I ever learned
as a human being was from Jeff Bezos,
and I've told this story a
couple of times on the channel.
But the idea is to live
life with no regrets.
Here was a guy who was having
massive success at his firm,
where he was the youngest vice president
ever at his company,
and he left it, he threw it all away
to start a business called Amazon,
where people thought he was crazy.
Who would ever buy books online?
Why are you throwing away
this successful career
to do this thing?
And his answer was, he didn't
want to live with regret.
He could live with it not working,
but he did not want to live with regret.
And so, he calls it, in
a very technical term,
the regret minimization framework,
where basically, whenever you're
afraid to make a decision,
fast forward your life to age 70,
you're looking back or maybe
by the time we get there,
90, 150, look back on your life,
say, "Am I going to regret
saying yes or saying no to this?"
And if you're going to regret it,
then take the opposite action.
Do it.
And so, this really came into play
into my life when I was in
Paris and I was a tourist,
and this girl came up and
asked me for directions.
And I wanted to ask her out
and I was too afraid to do it.
And I just pointed her in the
direction she wanted to go,
and I didn't ask her out.
And then, I took a picture
as she was walking across
the bridge to the other
side of the street,
and I didn't actually
get her in the picture.
I couldn't tell because it
wasn't digital at the time.
And I put that picture,
I printed it off big,
and I put it on my wall at home,
put it in my bedroom,
as a reminder not to live with regret,
as a reminder that next time
that I get in that situation,
where I want to do something
but I'm too afraid,
to do it because the
alternative is not knowing.
And you can deal with a
little bit of short term pain,
maybe you get rejected,
maybe it doesn't work out,
maybe she laughs at you, whatever it is.
You can deal with a little
bit of short term pain
versus of lifetime of not knowing.
And so, I had that picture on my wall,
and people thought it was
this beautiful French picture,
like yes.
I didn't tell anybody the story behind it.
And then, an opportunity
came later on that year
where I had a chance to go work
at the dream company I
thought I wanted to work at
versus being involved in
this startup biotech company
that wasn't making a lot of money
and making 300 bucks a month.
And that was part of what helped me decide
to stick with the company
and not go get the job,
where I would be making 80, 100k a year,
lots of opportunities,
the thing that all my friends wanted
and the company's flying me to New York,
putting me up in fancy hotels,
and wining and dining, all of that stuff.
Saying no to do this small company
that had a little chance of success,
hadn't proven itself at all,
I wasn't making any kind
of real money from it,
why would I do that?
Because I could live
with the company failing,
but I couldn't live with not knowing.
And so, I try to live my
life ever since that point
of reducing as many regrets as possible.
And every time I ask myself,
am I going to regret this,
as soon as I get an honest answer,
then I know what I have to do.
So, that's my story.
And the question of the day today is
what advice would you give
your 25-year-old self,
just like Ben Affleck did.
Leave it in the comments below.
Super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Liliana.
Liliana, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
Really, really, really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you
and hope you continue
to believe in yourself,
and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot
of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- We've only this one life.
And we should make the best of it.
That's what I try to.
To do the best is not to
enjoy each day as the last,
celebrating, drinking, whatever
because tomorrow it could be the end.
No, no, no, it's to
make it a better place.
I think it's only possible
in your surrounding.
You come in a room, try,
let the people don't feel
worse when you come in.
So, that's what I try to do,
that's how I understand life.
- I think a lot of times you think that
the great writers are the people,
they just write hit after hit after hit.
And they do, but it's also because
they get through all the
terrible songs first,
and I think that's kind of
every single artist story.
And I love to tout,
when people ask what's your best advice
for an upcoming musician or anybody,
I think it's that you have to be able
to rise from the failures is
what makes a successful person
because everybody's going to have mishaps,
they're going to fall down,
and it's the people that
continuously pick themselves up
that are the ones that are
going to find their voice,
make it, whatever you want to call it.